cuando el huracán y antojó tierra en el
oeste de Cuba llegó con Vientos de más
de 200 kilómetros por hora y una
marejada de 4 metros
de un salón para otro porque en aquello
había menos condiciones que este
por los cristales y todo eso al menos
50.000 cubanos fueron evacuados cientos
de miles se quedaron sin electricidad
entre tanto en la costa del Golfo de
Florida donde se espera que golpee el
huracán Ian los municipios han
distribuido gratuitamente sacos de arena
para protegerse de las inundaciones
Ahora nos estamos preparando para el
huracán tenemos nuestros sacos de arena
aquí ya los tenemos en la parte de atrás
estamos realmente preocupadas por la
marejada porque puede causar más daño
que la propia tormenta Así que nos
estamos preparando las autoridades
locales han declarado el estado de
emergencia y movilizado a la guardia
Nacional floridanos de la zona baja de
la Bahía de Tampa se enfrentan a órdenes
de evacuación obligatoria
y dicen evacuación obligatoria es hora
de ir otros planean refugiarse en el
lugar
es demasiado pronto para decirlo pero
nos abastecemos de agua y de lo básico
de pan y nuestras linternas están listas
tenemos un generador un generador de gas
para hacer funcionar nuestra nevera y
algunas luces si lo necesitamos Así que
no estamos demasiado preocupados
y han será el primer huracán en Florida
en una temporada que ha sido
inusualmente lenta en su